you know they say two and a half million
people die every year from alcohol
which is sad but think about how many
people it produces
it's got to be like three to one you
know
if my parents didn't drink I might not
be here I'm definitely gonna name my
kids after the substance that got them
conceived this is my daughter tequila
this is my son Jaeger what about that
kid hugging your leg that's Molly
oh man I was hungover last week couldn't
get out of bed you guys ever been so
hungover you see we're gonna be like as
an old person when you're really hung
over he basically turned into a senior
citizen right you wake up you don't know
how the hell you got there your body
hurts you're weak you're shaking you're
popping pills someone's like where are
your friends you're like I lost them all
about you like your old like we took him
out last night he himself okay
he made a scene he fell he blamed
everything on China